cette affaire d'état est grave
monsieur le premier ministre elle
symbolise la violence sociale mise en
oeuvre par votre gouvernement sur
directives du président de la république
l'arrogance et le mépris affiché chaque
semaine par le nouveau pouvoir met en
péril l'équilibré social et le pacte
républicain
ces faits ne sont pas des faits
anecdotiques
ce n'est pas un faux pas c'est
l'expression d'une politique autoritaire
dont les excès doivent aujourd'hui être
dénoncés vous savez madame la présidente
qu'une enquête préliminaire a été
ouverte par le procureur de paris
de toute évidence et je tiens à insister
sur ce point nous serons évidemment
déterminé à faire en sorte que cette
enquête préliminaire puisse permettre de
faire toute la lumière et que nous
puissions tirer toutes les conclusions
de cette enquête et de cette procédure
judiciaire engagée
je le dis je le dis parce que c'est
naturel de le dire parce que c'est ce à
quoi nous croyons et parce que c'est ce
que nous souhaitons la sphère elle est
désormais aux mains de la justice
et c'est très bien ainsi elle est
désarmée
elle est désormais aux mains de la
justice et c'est très bien ainsi
un certain nombre un certain nombre de
questions ne manqueront pas d'être posée
je souhaite nous souhaitons tous que
cette enquête permette de déterminer les
faits précis les raisons claires
l'enchaînement des décisions qui ont été
prises sur ce sujet je vous remercie
[Musique]
pourquoi n'y at il pas eu de saisine
immédiate du procureur de la république
en application de l'article 40 alinéa 2
du code de procédure pénale ce qui
aurait été le minimum en cette affaire
alors alors certes le parquet vient
d'ouvrir une enquête préliminaire
mais cela n'aurait pas eu lieu sans les
informations du journal le monde et
c'est très grave
monsieur le premier ministre nous vous
demandons la vérité sur cette affaire et
enfin une réaction à la mesure de sa
gravité
jetez un dès le début de mon
intervention comme l'a fait le premier
ministre a condamné sans ambiguïté un
acte inadmissible qui alors même qu'il
ne procède pas de l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre vient nuire à l'image
et au professionnalisme de leurs actions
il appartient comme dit le premier
ministre à la justice d'établir les
fêtes mais je veux souligner que ces
deux personnes n'avaient évidemment
aucune légitimité pour intervenir
elle avait été autorisée par la
préfecture de police de paris
assister en tant qu'observateur et
observateurs seulement au déroulement
d'un service de maintien de l'ordre
d'une manifestation
c'est là une pratique régulière qui
trouve sa justification dans une logique
de transparence et d'ouverture de
l'institution policière
c'est ce que font régulièrement
magistrats journalistes chercheurs pour
savoir dans quelles conditions
ceci s'est passé j'ai demandé à
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale
de préciser quelles sont les règles pour
l'accueil et l'encadrement de ces
observateurs
et s'il en existe de vérifier dans ce
cas précis qu elles ont été mises en
oeuvre
[Musique]